you
hi everyone it's Jerry man chest coms
tactics trainer and going to do a group
of three puzzles without any time limit
and just share my thoughts along the way
so in this first one playing as white
mm-hmm my my eye is immediately focused
on this black has something if we're not
quick rook takes g2 okay so probably a
very forcing move needed for starters
rook to a a is not good because if
Bishop takes it's a rule that out this
is a checking square or pivot square
Bishop g5 what loose pieces are there
uh-huh okay there we go
that question right they are asking that
question led me to this answer the
bishop on e4 is unprotected and we have
this checking move Queen h4 to pick the
bishop up and that'll be simple enough
then or will it mm-hmm
or will it so tempting isn't it huh this
is actually a little bit more involved
mm-hmm because after Queen h4 there is
the move Queen c7 yeah Queen e7 blocking
the check and also if then Queen takes
fish up there is now Queen takes rook we
have an unprotected piece it is true
that after Queen h4 king e 7 or excuse
me Queen h4 Queenie 7 Queen takes Bishop
Queen takes rook we can then target the
newly unprotected piece yeah we could
target the rook who's who is now
unprotected on G 8 by playing Queen d5
hmm and if King here we do not take the
rook because we get mated with Queen a1
however Queen h4 Queen e7 Queen takes
Bishop Queen takes rook Queen d5 check
if the King moves to one of the first
rank squares well one of the eighth rank
squares we take the rook with check the
other square is to e7 in which case we
don't take the rook but rather hit black
with the fork Bishop c5 I really like
this puzzle this highlights uh wow this
really highlights a lot forks
unprotected pieces and new pieces that
are unprotected as you're going through
your calculations visualizing the
different pieces moving and also we have
to recognize the the threats our
opponent has along the way mm-hmm you
know this is it Queen to h4 takes Bishop
Queen takes rook and now Queen here and
now we take the rook with check and
that'll be it yep and it's important
that on King here we don't take the rook
because it's not being captured with
check and it's a million to four black
we need one Bishop Locke's Queen takes
Bishop King here we would play Bishop to
c5 and pick up the Queen
I like that puzzle that was a good one
let's try another okay
confident with this one it's my first
impression ah let's see why do I feel so
confident mmm it's an in-game like
position I like the end games so let's
see if I could get this I know if we're
checking the night blocks we push the
pawn two on to d8
the knight will be pinned we could go d7
d 8 how are we looking material wise or
even we have a passed pawn hmmm unrep
check the knight does not have to block
King g7 and where do we go from there
where are the loose pieces in this one
look out for I don't really see a way
that we could take advantage of this
it's not really short on squares I could
go to d4 can't even attack it with g3 we
dropped the bishop so would this really
be the first move rook check King here
what's the great follow up also black is
in a position to take this pawn and
defend the night Oh interesting
uh-huh okay well actually this first
check is good I believe and then on King
g7 we bring the other rook into the
action upon 1 to e7 and this move rook
takes d6 now there is a case of a rook
being a protected and also they run the
risk of being in a pin there Knight and
rook are stacked here on d7 and d6 and
we can then play rook to d8 if the
knight budges we
simply push our pond so rook check King
g7 the other rook I wrote from 1 to e 7
and if rook takes pawn we play rook d8
the knight is pinned if he moves we grab
the rook
similarly on rook check King g7 rook 1
to e7 rook b7 yet again we play rip to
d8 the knight is attacked and he can't
move out of the way and defend the rook
because there's this e5 pawn there so I
believe that this is it and give a check
and then you know we put both of our
rooks on the 7th and 8th ranks force the
knight to move in which case we push our
pawn our Brooks will be there to
supporting its admit to our rooks we'll
be there to support its advance and if
the knight does not move and the rook
captures then they run into a pin one
way or the other
let's do it that is it and now the other
rook it's correct and then simply rook
d8 and that'll be it all right taking
advantage of a pin and that one and
let's try one more
mm-hmm ok this must be a mate problem ok
well my first thought was to do this but
that's illegal so let's try something
else
hmm
oh man I see the answer this is a cool
one this is a cool puzzle this is a
really cool puzzle ah man how did I see
it let me let me try to before I forget
here how did I come up with this answer
I believe the first move is Queen g7 wow
that's a pretty that's a pretty sharp
move well this is this is what ran
through my mind like really quick just
then I want to be able to play to g4
this is what I thought I thought I
started I looked at this move to deflect
the Queen off of this fifth rank and
then I thought can we just mate with the
ponds with g4 King here's the only move
g5 if the King goes to h5 and now we
play g4 and that's main that's not
working because I'm queen c5 Queen takes
g4 King h6 g5 the king can play to g7 so
then I thought how can we make it such
that the King cannot make use of g7 that
way our group of three pawns will be
able to give mate all by themselves
Queen to g7 we'll do that it's not check
but it's a fork if the rook moves here
to defend the Queen Queen takes h7 game
over yeah
black try something like queen d1
looking for mate our queen for a queen
on g7 well we would just play g4
she controls h6 so this is a pretty
serious move and I believe it's going to
play out like this Queen g7 Queen takes
g4 King h6 g5 king h5 and then finally
g4 this was a good one
yeah this was actually a really nice
group of three some interesting puzzles
in this group that is it and we go
straight in for this very cool mate down
a couple major pieces but that is in
fact me I'm in I really like this group
of three that first one really
highlighted some some neat things
recognizing those unprotected pieces
Forks and a couple situations and also
being a bit careful about the threats
your opponent has capturing a rogue
threatening back rank mate in that first
one yeah overall wow this was a really
nice group of three feel free to share
how you did in the comment section below
with these three puzzles and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye